on vous emmène à présent à la découverte
d'une entreprise et qui brasse de l'air
depuis 1976 et à qui ça rapporte à
vendôme à la société eco fit est
spécialisée dans les ventilateurs et
filtre à air avec le co vider la
nécessité de renouveler l'air ambiant
cette pme a connu dernièrement un rebond
de son activité avec la création de
nouveaux marchés et les explications de
samuel colin pourquoi la partie tournant
il commença à prendre forme de leurs
moteurs électriques à leurs hélices 75%
des ventilateurs fabriqués ici sont
exportés direction le tgv chinois
le tramway coréens ou encore les
magasins de nord-américains pour l'air
conditionné la réfrigération ou
chauffage
les besoins sont multiples et façon
fabricants asiatiques
les 130 salariés de vendôme tirent leur
épingle du jeu grâce à une production
facilement personnalisable et des
petites séries
notre capacité justement et dans
l'adaptation aux besoins de nos clients
je dirais que on a des produits
standards mais on a majoritairement des
produits complètement customisés l'usiné
montrée en exemple par le medef 41
l'organisation patronale créé le onzième
club strates extio de france l'idée un
regroupement de chefs d'entreprise qui
se réunissent tous les deux mois
bosser ensemble pour s'unir pour aller
ensemble à l'international et ils le
font à chaque fois sur une thématique
précise de l'international les barrières
douanières la croissance externe le
recrutement pour l'international les
différences culturelles des retours
d'expériences et des réunions autour de
spécialistes pour mieux définir sa
stratégie à l'export le loir-et-cher
compte dans son club pour commencer six
autres entreprises à côté déco feat